today i want to cover bootstrap startups
versus
funded startups now we need to
set some ground rules here and some
basic understanding of what we're
talking about
bootstrapping comes from the term
pulling one up by their own bootstraps
which
is a physical impossibility i think
bootstraps are little straps on the back
of your boots that help you put your
boots on okay we get it
bootstrapping is like you can pull
yourself over the fence with your
bootstrap it doesn't exactly make sense
but the term basically means you're able
to create a company
off of either sweat equity
or revenue that you immediately start
generating so what are examples of that
a consulting business where you say i'm
willing
to charge you a hundred dollars for
every hour
for me to be a consultant to you well
immediately if you sell 10 hours a week
the company's got revenue on day one
it is really easy to bootstrap
and it all it requires is if you're
going to be
in one of these venture capital
categories all it requires
is that you are a designer a developer
or
somehow a business a sales person
a marketer one of those skills and you
kind of need to have all three of those
to be totally honest to get most of
these companies off the ground
that's why a lot of accelerators like y
combinator or others insist on having a
developer on the founding team if it's a
technology company
that's high growth how are you gonna
have a technology come with high growth
if you don't have a developer
you're not in all likelihood and if it's
an outsourced
uh development shop that's a red flag
why can't you get a developer on your
core team
why can't you be a developer and so
there is a bias
against people who are idea people
there's a bias against marketers there
is a bias
against idea people or quote unquote
business people
in fact i've heard many venture
capitalists say business person means
no skill that you have no skill that
you're just an mba with an idea
maybe you can build a model et cetera
now you do need to have leaders to hire
everybody and bring the band together
so i don't necessarily feel that way but
i think a lot of people in silicon
valley
think in order to be successful that
management team
those co-founders at the start need to
be developer
ux designer product designer product
manager there's a lot of different names
for basically the person who architects
conceptually the product
product manager pm uh ux
ui designer user experience user
interface those are the terms
that and the titles that people get
excited about when they see a team
so if your team was an idea person
like i am let's be honest i'm kind of an
idea person and a marketer
uh business guy that's fine but you need
to have a collaborator and i did brian
alvey was
my cto and my collaborator on weblogsync
and
that made me go a long way and had mark
jeffrey as my cto when i did mahalo
and then moved on to inside so having
and i was also product guy so
having a product person a you know
designer product person sometimes those
are two different skills by the way you
have a designer who just makes things
beautiful
and a ux person who works on the user
interface and how the product flows
but you do need to have that in order to
bootstrap because the worst case
scenario is you give money
to a startup they hire an outsourced dev
firm
the dev firm says okay you stopped
paying us this month you've been paying
us for 10 months the product's out
and then the product doesn't work
there's no developers to work on it and
the company
goes backwards so um one
other caveat here is something called
friends and family money
friends and family money is when you
are not qualified to get venture capital
and you go to your friends and your
family
your associates maybe people you've
worked with and say hey i'm passing the
hat i'm trying to raise money
and then i'm gonna take that money i'm
gonna hire people and maybe you can with
that friends and family money kickstart
the project to get enough traction to
get into an accelerator or
to get venture capital pretty hard to do
uh not everybody's got the rich uncle or
rich aunt who
are willing to throw 100 grand or 250
grand at a project but some people do
some people uh will keep their day job
there's another bootstrapping technique
keep your day job and build on the
weekends and nights or
go to your boss and say hey i'm willing
to stay on for two days a week
and i would like this consulting fee and
then the other three days a week you
work on your startup or
you know three days at your current
company two days on your startup a lot
of people will
start the flywheel going that way do
their user interviews
understand customers do their research
build their mvp
you want to have your landing ready
before you take off is basically how i
would describe this
so if you're going to take off and go
out over the ocean
you better have the landing in mind and
you better have enough fuel
fuel in this case would be your personal
runway personal runway would be
okay you've got five thousand dollars a
month in bills and payments and rent and
whatever
okay it's going to take you 18 months to
build this company out to the point at
which you get venture capital
do you personally have 18 times five do
you have a hundred grand 90 grand 100
110 grand with a buffer in your bank
account to keep you
solvent while you spend a year and a
half of your life trying to get this
startup off the ground
and i did that a lot of my startups i
was working as a consultant or i had a
little bit of cash
from the previous project in my bank
account or i
went into debt which is very dangerous
uh you know and
not for everybody but there is risk
you're not entitled to be a startup
founder or you get venture capital
you must understand this when you come
to the table and decide you want to work
in this space so we talked a little bit
about bootstrapping versus vc
if you bootstrap the longer you
bootstrap
then the less dilution you will have to
your cap table
so let's pause on that for a second if
you raise money from that friends and
family around and you raise 250k
you might get a two and a half two and a
half million dollar valuation you've
given away 10 percent of your company
for that 250.
now if you find a co-founder who's a
developer and you're a designer ux
person you don't need the 250 because
you're not going to give it to an
outside firm so the two of you just
build it on the weekends or nights
now you have no dilution now you get
the product to a prototype phase and you
go to a seed fund or an accelerator
and you raise a hundred k for six
percent of your company at an
accelerator
or you get a seed fund to put 250 500 k
and let's say
had a five million dollar valuation well
now you
got to the product done and you got 500k
and you diluted 10
as opposed to in the previous scenario
you would have spent the 250
gotten the product to launch and then
taken another 500k
from a seed fund and deluded another 10
in other words
you would have given away over 20
percent of your business you would have
less than 80 percent
and you would have raised 750. the
longer you can push out the funding and
the more you can accomplish with less
the less funding you have to do we call
this a pegasus or i came up with the
term pegasus so there's unicorns
companies worth over a billion dollars
but a pegasus for me as a company that
flies over
through the wings of bootstrapping they
fly over funding rounds and they skip
funding rounds and i encourage you to
think about how can i grow this business
so strong
that i can skip my next round of funding
it's very out of
favor right now everybody loves to raise
funding it's such a hot market in 2021
valuations are high why wouldn't you
take money off the table that's true
and that is a true statement money is
sloshing around everywhere
people are raising money at very high
valuations i don't blame them for doing
that
a lot of advice is situational right so
i'm giving you this advice
based on a certain situation which
should be a normal market in a hot
market yeah if you can raise money at a
high price
you know the same example i just gave if
you were raising that first 250 at a 10
million
valuation it's only two and a half
percent dilution who cares right
uh so that would be a de minimis amount
of dilution you can go for it
but some companies like web flow bubble
com.com notion have skipped rounds of
funding
and we were involved in com.com and we
watched them skip two rounds of funding
three rounds of funding
and that meant our percentage ownership
along with the founders
was very high because we didn't dilute
and then as the company came worth and
worth more and more we didn't have to
put up a bunch of
pro rata we didn't have to keep
investing to keep our percentage
ownership
and that was amazing for everybody every
startup needs business insurance and you
should look no further than a broker if
you don't have insurance
you fail one of the first steps in
broker technology saves you time
and money prices are up to 20 percent
lower with better coverage
than the incumbents you can go from sign
up to quote and purchase in just 10
minutes when you work within broker
instead of business insurance incumbents
you're not dealing with large slow
corporations
plus the sign up takes days not weeks
and the process is transparent with no
opaque pricing
here are four crucial types of startup
insurance that
they cover and you're going to need all
four of these in all likelihood
cyber insurance in case you get hacked
dno insurance
so your if your directors and officers
do something dumb and you get sued
you're covered
you have eno insurance which covers
errors and omissions that's what the e
and the o stands for and
it helps you scale because many major
customers will ask
to see your eno insurance in order to
close a deal and of course
epl employment practices liability
discovers harassment wrongful
termination
and more to instantly buy custom built
insurance for
startups go to inbroker.com twist
that's e-m-b-r-o-k-e-r dot com
slash twist and while you're there get
an extra 10 off using the offer code
twist you guessed it okay let's get back
to this amazing episode